[Musica]
nell'estate del 2015
sono stata contattata per entrare a far
parte di un progetto giornalistico
segreto già nome era molto ambizioso si
chiamava progetto prometeo come appunto
il nome dell'eroe greco che portò via il
fuoco agli dei per darlo agli uomini che
cosa dobbiamo fare dobbiamo controllare
un database fatto di documenti
provenienti da uno studio legale
panamense mossa fonseca specializzato
nella creazione di società off shore in
paradisi fiscali
si trattava di ben 2.6 tera di materiale
vedete quello in rosso e vedete cosa
succede nella parte in alto che cosa era
il contenuto di wikileaks ecco quello
era un mix quello in rosso è il
materiale che dovevamo esaminare noi che
cosa abbiamo trovato che cosa c'era in
questi documenti c'erano degli ex el dei
fogli award delle e mail dei pdf persino
degli audio
il nostro obiettivo secondo quello che
c'è stato cast era di trovare individui
e società legate paradisi fiscali per
l'obiettivo finale era quello di vedere
chi avendo queste società era in qualche
modo autore di un crimine perché
magari utilizzava queste società per il
riciclaggio del denaro piuttosto che per
fondi usati per il terrorismo o anche
semplicemente per eludere o evadere il
fisco del proprio paese
abbiamo lavorato in 400 giornalisti da
tutto il mondo
pensate a mettere assieme 400 persone
con menti completamente diverse che si
devono ritrovare segretamente e devono
mantenere questo patto il punto di
segretezza per poter lavorare con
tranquillità tranquillità perché c'era
stato ha prospettato un fortissimo
rischio nel momento della pubblicazione
un rischio fisico e anche un rischio
cibernetico nel senso di rischio di
hackeraggio
insomma capite che non potevamo dire di
no nel momento in cui uno ti dice ma fai
questo lavoro non sai che cosa troverai
e rischi la tua vita
ovviamente è quello che un giornalista
d'inchiesta cui non può sottrarsi ha
però a convincermi a fare questo era il
fatto che invitarmi fosse ai si legge i
consorzi internazionali di giornalisti
d'inchiesta di washington
un centro che da quasi vent'anni fa
questo per professione ovvero mette
assieme giornalisti di tutto il mondo da
diverse redazioni da diverse realtà o
anche freelance per indagare su uno
stesso tema
ecco che quindi segreto questo si è
creato questo gruppo di 400 persone che
sono state messi in una sorta di social
network privato no in cui comunicavamo
tra noi
pensate no ad avere persone dal giappone
piuttosto che dalla cina dalla francia
dal sudamerica in ogni momento della
giornata noi ci potevamo connettere in
questa sorta di social network e avere
qualcuno dall'altra parte del mondo che
stava collegato e quindi potevamo
confrontarci anche insomma semplicemente
sfogarci se non trovavamo nulla
l'importante tutto questo la regola
principale era che ogni cosa che noi
avessimo trovato all'interno del
database è rilevante ai fini appunto
era quello di condividerlo con tutti i
colleghi fare esattamente quello che il
giornalismo tradizionale non fa perché
quando una testata un giornalista trovo
una cosa ovviamente il suo scooter
ottiene tutto per sé
invece noi dovevamo fare esattamente il
contrario quindi scardinare
completamente alle regole del
giornalismo tradizionale e dire anche al
collega dell'altro paese piuttosto che
se c'erano altri colleghi del nostro
stesso posto del nostro stesso della
nostra stessa nazione e quindi di
testate magari diverse guarda io ho
trovato questo tu magari trovato
qualcos'altro lo mettiamo assieme ci
confrontiamo e facciamo in modo di unire
i puntini e trovare degli elementi in
più trovare materiali all'interno di
questi documenti era veramente l'ago nel
pagliaio nel senso che si trattava di 12
milioni di e mail quindi un sacco di
materiale molto di questo non utile ai
fini giornalistici solo qualcosa è stato
appunto poi utilizzato e ed è stato un
risultato che poi ha portato a questa
inchiesta ha pensate che in 400 abbiamo
dovuto persino decidere assieme il nome
da dare a quest'inchiesta udine va beh
insomma ma pensate che cosa vuol dire
scegliere il nome ad esempio anche
semplicemente di un figlio tra due
persone due partner
pensate che cosa vuol dire scegliere un
nome di un'inchiesta che sarebbe dovuta
essere utilizzato come titolo dai
giornali argentini piuttosto che a
quelli francesi e da tutti quanti ma
abbiamo dovuto decidere anche un'altra
cosa assieme cioè la data di
pubblicazione
tutti quanti quelli che avevano aderito
hanno aderito a questo progetto hanno
dovuto accettare il fatto che la data di
pubblicazione sarebbe stato il 3 aprile
2016 alle ore 8 di sera italiane
da allora in poi si sarebbero potute
pubblicare in ogni momento anche un mese
dopo bastava non un solo minuto secondo
prima di quella data del barba
ecco che così sono nati panama papers la
più grande collaborazione giornalistica
investigativa della storia che ha
portato alle dimissioni di una serie di
persone tra cui il primo ministro
dell'islanda ministri di diversi paesi
ha fatto vacillare dei governi e da poco
ha portato anche alla chiusura di questo
studio legale panamense massa fonseca ha
portato in prigione di una serie di
persone ha messo a rischio una serie di
colleghi giornalisti e è stata
riconosciuta da con il premio pulitzer
per la prima volta ha dato quindi anche
a dei giornalisti italiani non ci siamo
fermati a questo
a parte il fatto che marilyn streep da
pochi giorni anche deciso di
interpretare un film sui par panama
papers pochi giorni
poche settimane successive alla questa a
questo lavoro
tutto si è rimesso in moto perché sono
arrivate di documenti da altri studi
legali su cui abbiamo lavorato di nuovo
per mesi e mesi di nuovo con un gruppo
corposo di centinaia di giornalisti e
questo ha dato vita a un inchiesta più
recente quella di paradise papers che è
stata pubblicata a partire dal novembre
dello scorso anno
questo è un modello di giornalismo
diverso che rompe i confini e le
concezioni tradizionale del giornalismo
cui siamo abituati che quello che in
genere finisce termine nelle redazioni
dei nostri giornali delle nostre
televisioni delle radio
per me è stato un po il fatto di portare
a frutto anche tutto il mio percorso di
educazione è stato diciamo una
conclusione di questo di questa mia
formazione
io ho sempre voluto in qualche modo fare
un lavoro che mi permettesse di scavare
a fondo trovare risultati e poi in
qualche modo condividere questi
ritrovamenti con le persone
avete capito che volevo fare
l'archeologa insomma addirittura posto
di fare indiana jones
questo
insomma molto semplicemente poi insomma
ho capito che è un po complesso mi sono
comunque guardato attorno e ho visto che
potevo applicare questo anche al
giornalismo e quindi dopo una formazione
legata al studio delle lingue orientali
in particolare il giapponese il cinese e
poi studi di finanza e di giornalismo è
arrivato anche per me un momento
particolare banco di prova che è stato
quello del 2011 con il terremoto tsunami
e conseguente crisi nucleare di
fukushima e e fu un momento in cui
decisi ok questo è un momento per me per
andare partire e andare a vedere che
cosa è successo in quei posti per poi
raccontarlo attraverso i media qui con
cui collaboro ricordo che all'epoca
simpaticamente e timidamente i miei
genitori tenta rondi così mettermi
qualche dubbio ma sei sicura buscema
sicuro radiazioni insomma non è che
proprio fosse posto più tranquillo della
terra e io li consola dicendo mamma
insomma mamma papà ciò la mia amica che
sta in sudamerica e sta seguendo i
narcos l'altra che in azerbaigian e in
sta seguendo le guerre piuttosto che in
pakistan un altre molti colleghi che si
stanno occupando di criminalità
organizzata il sud italia
io alla fine vado soltanto a fukushima e
mi ricordo che mio padre
cercò di così frena mi dicendo ma tesoro
ma non puoi semplicemente cambiare
amiche però diciamo che non ebbe grande
effetto e ha davanti lo stesso da buona
testarda la mia generazione di
giornalisti come forse anche quella
precedente ma in particolare la nostra
sofferto una serie di obiezioni
una in particolare no quella che ci
dicevano lascia perdere non fate i
giornalisti perché quell epoca del
giornalista ma infinita e non troverete
mai lavoro non farete mai più quel
lavoro che si faceva una volta
forse è vero se pensate la figura dei
giornalisti è sempre stato un po questa
nove persone che andavano
in giro o piuttosto che insomma
raccoglievano informazioni ed erano poi
custodi
gli unici custodia delle informazioni
che poi ci venivano trasferite
attraverso i giornali le tv e le radio e
noi dovevamo credere avere fiducia in
queste persone da italia erano gli unici
poi con l'avvento del digitale
molte persone quasi tutti sono diventati
in qualche modo non ho acquisito la
possibilità di dare delle informazioni
di metterle online
e vero false che fossero ad ogni modo
contribuivano ad arricchire il numero di
informazioni a disposizione tanto che
sono tantissime tanto che a un certo
punto ci si è arrivati a chiedere ma
perché c'è ancora bisogno del
giornalista ma c'è davvero ancora
bisogno di una figura che vada a dirmi
magari quello che io leggo già in altre
fonti era domanda lecita la mia risposta
per questa io credo che nessuno o pochi
dopo una giornata lavorativa intensa o
durante qualche pausa abbiano ancora le
forze per potersi mettere ad esempio a
guardare 2.6 terra di materiale a
poterlo confrontare a fare interviste
andare a verificare ogni dato a spendere
ore e ore di ricerca e anche a mettere a
repentaglio la propria vita per questo e
poi pochi credo hanno ancora la voglia e
la forza di mettersi a trovare dei modi
per comunicare quello che si è trovato
all'interno di questi dati e trasferirlo
quindi alla comunità per fare un
servizio anche questo è un lavoro molto
complesso che va al di là della ricerca
ma che riguarda la condivisione di
questo materiale con tutti
negli stati uniti si è trovato questo
sistema non quello di centri di
giornalismo non profit indipendenti che
generano del contenuto che poi viene
diffuso e dato alle diverse testate no
noi in italia abbiamo cercato di fare lo
stesso e abbiamo creato per la prima
volta il primo centro di giornalismo
d'inchiesta indipendente sul modello
sono e lanciato nel 2013 si chiama irpi
sta per investigative reporting project
italy
produciamo contenuto e poi lo
diffondiamo le diverse testate lo
produciamo in modo indipendente ci
occupiamo in particolare di criminalità
organizzata italiana da cosa nostra
ndrangheta delle mafie straniere in
italia della nostra mafia esportata
all'estero ci occupiamo di evasione
fiscale e anche di altri tipi di crimini
il cuore portante della nostra attività
il fatto che tutte le cose di cui noi ci
occupiamo partono dall'italia mano in
qualche modo una connessione con
l'esterno e questo non è troppo
difficile visto che sappiamo ormai
crimini non ha confini e quindi anche
giornalismo deve avere più confini
la nostra forza sta nel fatto della rete
perché ogni volta che lui intraprendiamo
un percorso andiamo a fare un'inchiesta
quando ci porta fuori ci appoggiamo e
consorziamo con giornalisti di altri
paesi esperti di quella stessa materia
che noi stiamo andando indagare
noi portiamo nelle nostre informazioni
loro ci danno e loro le scambiamo e
questo aumenta intanto la rafforza
fortemente la capacità di penetrazione e
d'indagine nostra e perché si hanno
degli esperti del post si supera anche
quindi problema linguistico perché un
conto si va in un paese che parla
inglese un conto è se si va ad esempio
in paesi in cui la lingua inglese non è
quella prevalente le comunicazioni
diventano molto difficili quindi avere
una persona sul posto che ne sa è di
grande aiuto
questo aumenta anche l'impatto poi di
quello che noi andiamo a diffondere
perché pensate 2 paese significa già due
pubblicazioni due paesi diversi no e il
c consorziamo sempre sul modello
dell'embargo quindi assieme decidiamo
quando uscire in modo tale da
amplificare rafforzare la nostra uscita
come si mantengono questi sistemi non
abbiamo finanziamenti pubblici ma
abbiamo e nemmeno una pubblicità non
nemmeno gli sponsor
abbiamo spesso ci appoggiamo a delle
fondazioni che fanno questo da anni sono
in fondazioni indipendente che
finanziano il giornalismo d'inchiesta di
questo tipo e con dei bandi e delle
procedure si ricevono dei finanziamenti
o per singole inchieste piuttosto che
per l'intero lavoro che per la struttura
insomma per il mantenimento della
struttura della organizzazione e poi ci
sono i filantropi questa figura che
esiste soprattutto nel mondo americano
inglese
questa persona magari un imprenditore
che ha del denaro e decide di donarlo a
volte anche rimanendo anonimo ed è
pronto addirittura ad essere lui stesso
essere il primo indagato nel caso le
nostre inchieste ci portino anche a lui
capite che un grandissimo affare chi non
lo fa e quindi capite quanto sia
difficile che questo modello possa
attecchire ad esempio in italia ma noi
abbiamo fiducia siamo sicuri che ci
saranno persone che vanno andranno oltre
questo limite e decideranno di
finanziare questo tipo di lavoro perché
è importante finanziare questo tipo di
lavoro perché ci permette di superare
una serie di limiti che sono quelli
dell'editoria nostra che sono quelli
dell'editore che decide di non
pubblicarli qualcosa perché può essere
scomodo permette anche di proteggersi
l'un l'altro nel senso che facciamo rete
nel dicembre del 2014
una collega azzera cadice smile ove è
stata fermata e arrestata perché stava
indagando sulla corruzione del suo paese
prima di essere condannata a sette anni
di prigione ha contattato i giornalisti
del network tra cui anche noi di irpi
dando le carte su cui stava investigando
e ha chiesto a noi di portare avanti le
sue indagini si è creato un gruppo di
giornalisti centinaia che hanno lavorato
sui suoi documenti hanno portato avanti
le sue inchieste non nonostante lei
fosse stata messa in prigione e
addirittura abbiamo trovato una serie di
collegamenti anche con l'italia
così nel 2016 la corte suprema è stata
costretta a
scarcerarla e l'impatto che ha avuto
questa inchiesta e la risonanza a
livello internazionale è stato
fortissimo
lo scorso anno un'altra collega che
stava investigando sulle carte del
panama pepe si chiamava dafne caruana
galiziana giornalista mantese è stata
fatta esplodere davanti a casa sua con
un'autobomba
non ci siamo fermati
abbiamo deciso di andare avanti 45
giornalisti a 18 paesi si sono
consorziate tra loro hanno deciso di
portare avanti la sua inchiesta anche se
lei non c'era più
alessandra mi avvicino a te perchè
da collega condivido non solo quello che
hai detto è il ricordo di daphne ma la
tua reazione la tua profonda commozione
e comunque n'è uscito il daf nel project
che sta ancora in corso ricordiamo che
qualche mese fa è stato assassinato a
casa sua assieme alla fidanzata già
incrocia con un giornalista sul palco
stava lavorando con noi dirvi anche le
sue storie non moriranno voi vi
chiederete perché noi continuiamo a fare
questo lavoro diciamo sembriamo a volte
un po pazzi ma noi ci crediamo veramente
e pensiamo che nonostante tutto quello
che si possa dire dei giornalisti vi
chiedo questa cosa di pensare che ci
sono anche queste persone che in
silenzio a volte con umiltà portano
avanti questo lavoro lo fanno perché
credono che sia importante darvi delle
informazioni libere per permettervi di
decidere della vostra vita e di quella
delle persone che vi stanno attorno
noi facciamo questo la scelta e voi
[Applauso]
io non mi chiedo perché tu lo faccia lo
facciano gli altri
essendo un uomo pratico se avessi il
fisico ti farei da guardia del mondo
ciao di rete grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]